hello welcome to game spots now playing
of the crew I'm Danny I'm driving
and Andy here no it's my there's only
one wheel what was this nonsense give me
the wheels I'm a passenger attack here
can you please drive safe sorry tie
roots in the back what's up he's not
allowed to drink he's not let drive
because he's been drinking all day I
have been so no dice we have a fourth
seat here but I don't I don't know if
anyone else we might pull over later and
pick somebody else up I don't know they
give us a holler we're gonna play the
crew a game that I have not played ever
Ty you played a bit right I did a little
bit they said open up on beta uh today
on PC in peace in fact we're giving away
a bunch of codes yeah if you want to win
codes all you have to do is shout them
at the crew in the comments on the
Gamespot page do that right now we got a
bunch of Codes North America only sadly
I think they open
I love you play I'll make sure you do
not get a code uh okay I'm gonna
actually drive the entire time do it can
we first of all do you mind if you just
look at America because it's kind of
cool yeah so look at Florida it looks
like there's like a malignant growth oh
my god oh yeah what's this what's going
on here you have like the keys kind of
there they're kind of connected and then
you have like like Florida looks like it
got short and fat look at the Everglades
like most young boys in Texas when they
grow up I think no one would notice
their gross misunderstanding it's not
well it's gameplay man it's made by the
it's made by a French studio right I
mean well that is true yeah so and also
like every Tower is like they put
together like all these like like these
like Veterans of like racing franchises
and then just kind of said hey make this
awesome game and the best thing about
using fake cities is that you get to
make fun cities that burner Paradise
taught us anything it's the fiction is
often better than fact and they've kind
of merged the two I guess we should
visit you think yeah okay that's what I
want to do first sadly I don't think
Ireland is here in fact if I try and
zoom in any further uh go I think you go
to space it's not doing it anymore
already Arana did it it was really weird
is there like any part of Texas it has
to be that little that thing is Texas
right there in the South where is it the
mountain states no no go to your right
go go east black Maps is that Texas
that's not Texas okay media crazy meteor
craters
Hill Country go go west or east right
there Hill Country Hill Country yeah
that's it that's my home that's your
home
wow of course there's no cities there is
that it it's new isn't it wrong New
Braunfels yeah no way
that is like the Walmart area of like
Texas that's more like Schlitterbahn is
it's like this water park oh Padre
Island I've been Padre Island
it sounds like Austin that's weird
Maggiano's sounds like a racist made-up
type what is that Dallas is here oh they
have Dallas and not Austin look at
McDonald's Dallas sucks like there's
nothing remarkable right now sorry
Dallas no [__] you Dallas no seriously
look at the farmer's market let's see
who's at the farmer's market look how
deep you can go in this thing look at
these cars the cars are just random
let's go
fender bender
like that's this is still the map it's
kind of cool right are the cops can come
you can do that look at this I think you
can place your car anywhere like on that
thing I think this is based on Dallas
driving records so it's accurate I guess
at a waypoint
no it's a beta I don't think they give
you the whole country even the beta I
thought they were opening up after you
went to the whole tutorial kind of
mission
all right
okay should we stop doing this like she
plays the game okay we need to visit
everyone's Hometown all right where's
your hometown in Salt Lake City where's
Salt Lake up here right it's by that
like Las Vegas
oh that's cool because that is kind of
like car culture thing oh yeah well they
set land speed records there oh yeah so
of course they would have it in the car
game so what's that is that Salt Lake
City there it's not near death now it's
Las Vegas that's my hometown by the way
I was born you were born in Vegas you
conceived in Vegas probably what do you
think how come you didn't stay in Vegas
my parents by the way told me like when
I was 18. they had me out of wedlock but
I'm okay with it nice work I was a happy
accident
oh yeah
Salt Lake Resorts that's pretty much
where I'm from that's Park City probably
yeah there's only one street where
you're from look at it can we drive on
there now no there's really no bridges
that big anything look at that look at
Deep whoa really it's like Google Maps
this is kind of cool let's play the
skiing mini game oh look at these guys
this is almost as good a new game this
is this is almost have you heard that
game snow
yeah I remember saying shut up shut up
we get you on a live scene when you
start talking about snow automatically
I'm sorry are the chat getting pissed
off the way up and start playing the
game um
does it matter I'm gonna I'm gonna go
straight I want to see San Francisco
look at me San Francisco is like seven
blocks wide actually they have the
bridge they do have the bridge they got
both hey see if it's the new bridge or
the one that's gonna fall into the water
okay imagine how much rent would cost if
that's happening
it's the the Old Eastern spot am I
allowed to curse on this well you
already have like five times don't worry
about it this is where I live right here
right beside the Presidio look at that
that's not what it was actually had the
Presidio there that's great did it have
all the homeless dudes banging each
other that's I believe that's closer to
the water
this is great Castro is right by Twin
Peaks that's great this is uh this is
interesting go to our office Bay Area go
to where we are now it's in Soma okay so
it's here there it's one streak we see
18 T come in enhanced enhance look there
it is there's our office that's it
there's our office right there look at
all the traffic Jesus Christ get out of
the way all of those are look they've
all got pink mustaches on the front of
them
all right should we play this video game
and stop using Google Maps
I like how they're like it's definitely
not one to one it's pretty good right
French oh no this is one to one people
just don't know American that's all this
is French cool man all right well here
we are and we've already um the first
mission we couldn't figure out a way of
resetting the game it was basically a
very quick tutorial level where you run
away from the the popo
uh but yeah this is I would love someone
to verify if it is Troy Baker who's the
voice of this Alex guy the voice of the
crew yeah like in the story mode it
sounds it sounds like um kanji from
Persona 4 Gold okay like it's pretty
funny I mean it's all part of the same
universe
all right so the crew is a for those of
you who don't know is a is in I guess an
open world driving game which is a fully
connected uh not this similar from brand
new Paradise I feel like Camaro what is
that
oh man
it's a classic American Muscle right
there
Danny you're from Ireland I am what is
like the car is there is there a big car
culture in Ireland they're drifting yeah
kind of so is it like is like Skyline
GTS or like do you like American Muscle
like well I mean obviously there is no
America it's like skylines and like
Subarus and there's like stuff like that
like Nissans what about like a European
like what's the what's the most popular
car in that area oh I couldn't tell you
across the board probably like the
bladder if you just take Moscow because
America is like there's such a huge car
culture here it's like it's it's you
know it's kind of born here so it's like
segmented I guess kind of like it is
across the states so that's what that
guy [__] up hey dude that's a player
it's like the second level you can't be
crashing already bro
if you have any questions dude dude
you're supposed to drive on the Russians
right now I'll yell out the window
Brandon you're messing up alongside
wrong side he's over here Brandon's over
here
I'm gonna just sit here and beep at him
and be like you guys could just drive
you idiot look at this look he thinks
he's gonna get it at the end is he oh he
thinks he's going to get it so it's like
I was reading up about this apparently
there's like one instance I'm sorry
there's multiple instances but it's like
one it's like peer-to-peer serving here
so like there's no like I think the
eight people Max can be in your game
uh yo Brandon you suck at video games
hey can you oh man I keep wanting you to
get out the car and make fun of them you
can't do that so yeah it's honk
I got him
they're like NOS in this game I think
there is like the energy drink like
Motor Storm
um
we're gonna leave Brian to do his owner
man
look at these guys you jerk
so you say you're saying you think it's
all one instance well no so it's not one
instance I think it's like it's I think
they use some weird proprietary
technology where it's like it's like
peer-to-peer okay but there's not
there's there's like one main server but
it's all done through peer-to-peer and
other things that's why like they were
able to kind of do stuff like this but
you can only have I think eight people
Max in your game okay okay I'm gonna
keep saying cycling through those eight
people yeah so like it yeah it just when
someone leaves it pushes another person
in but like they said that they were
trying to make us like it'd be somebody
from like your either your friends list
or in the same geographical location
okay so like it's it's smartly pulling
them in sorry yeah it was interesting
Tech I was kind of reading about it
trying to understand what exactly they
were doing because I thought it was like
is this they can't obviously have
everybody on at once I mean there'd be
it'd be like LA traffic dude this is
like a really
good car to give you early off I'm
really I really like the handling it's
like it's oh
burnout in this there man
all right let's set a waypoint and find
out what we're actually going to do here
all right
map
back here okay where do you want to go
should we go to Detroit looks like it's
happening so that's like your hub
welcome to be starting you're there
all right wait so you're not on a
mission anymore you can go wherever you
want now let me yeah you just it's like
Burnout Paradise I believe is that
that's one thing I think you could
actually you could drive to Vegas if you
went through it I I don't think we can
debate it is there anything oh what
really Oh wrong way you can try you can
try well I I I don't know where we are
in the game it looks like we're still
kind of in that story Mission Part in
the beginning but oh okay yeah you have
like Direction line above you yeah
that's kind of Awesome
yeah this is not oh it's not i-76.
I like how essentially that's like uh
you guys you guys ever see Tango in cash
what they did to their truck
you're showing your range I've seen them
hey but no one in the Chinese I'm an old
man okay oh
should I be like moving side by side
here yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my God it's
like one of those uh when they film TV
shows in the car everybody
have you seen the Star Trek uh stuff
that's been uh you want to get in a seat
with me we need a passenger hey Danny
pull over real quick Danny pull over oh
look it's a pull over all right come on
let's go why are we picking up this
woman on the side of the motorway she
needs a ride she needs a ride
oh
okay I'm really liking the sensual lamp
yeah waypoints it's great okay
and everything don't actually drive by
the way
God
we really have to go look at Robert's
like bad kids bad
what'd you say it's not gonna give you a
racing line ever I think so yeah yeah
which is uh I don't know I'm kind of
into it
you know what we're playing
for Robert hey what's up Robert you know
what
this runs
oh I'm blocking Marin oh no are you
standing for the whole thing Andy no all
right he's just here for now oh there we
go I thought we would just pull are we
good all right that's Ty we got any
questions from the chat uh let me look
here um
kiss his life that's not quite a
question but not really at all it's
really just okay
um are we there yet no we're not clearly
driving game most of the game involves
driving are we there yet that's funny I
like what he did yeah right that was
good there's also a really horrible
movie
with like Ice Cube or the rock or
somebody you saw that nice
hey okay
look at this thing flipping out above me
I'm really into this I feel like even
though it runs at 30 FPS it still looks
pretty hey boxy drivers stop talking
over me
anymore
I have to go to the bathroom get out
I feel like after this all other car
games are going to kind of want to do
this uh
well guns missiles racing ones look at
this not smooth it was a driver look at
this it's during it it's asking me to do
this like incredibly dangerous challenge
it's not like they're in the car what's
it called car Cross or something oh God
that it's kind of cool my dad let me
stop and get some beef jerky
you were quiet
I don't know how life
are we on
okay we're almost there hopefully there
are a bunch of challenges here so
apparently there's some sort of a root
storyline tie how far have you gone to
this
uh this is kind of where I dropped off
this is right after right here we go
oh this area that's your dude
it's Troy Baker no so I think this main
mission we're going to in the center of
town is part of the uh yeah the the sort
of the narrative weave that's going to
pull you from City of the city hopefully
it is kind of cool how you keep passing
different
uh other player characters and robbing
them off the road sorry
Danny someone wants to know what Tunes
you listen to in the car when you're
picking up here we go
are you miked up Mary
Turn Down for What
all the time
hope not because it's not legal yeah I
played less than 30 seconds We're not
gonna get sued uh there is a full-on
radio in this bad boy actually just pull
over for a second
uh what we got here
where's the music from the
is it a root is it a
I think it's just a little MP3 player
from the [__] let's go on here of
course this is beta on the PC version
you'll probably be able to load yourself
what would you say about the graphics I
don't know you couldn't say on
boardman's collection how does it looks
yeah uh serviceable we're playing this
on a pretty high-end PC for those at
home we're wondering
um
it looks fine uh I don't know it doesn't
look racing game delicious this is what
I got by the way right here it's like
here it's like a big scale thing rather
than oh this is my stop thanks you guys
for no worries thanks Mary
twenty dollars
plus tab
here we go it's gonna it's gonna charge
your credit card automatically you're
fine it's an Uber yeah it's like an Uber
yeah
oh what oh this is perfect for that song
all right here we go look at this all
right can we get a little more gameplay
out here guys
I think we need GT wow that's a four GT
so what I am actual brands that I have
in this bad boy I saw a Nissan GTR
or gt so I was looking at the car list
there's not a lot okay yeah I mean
there's you have like obviously you have
like the American Muscle your Camaros
your uh Mustang Shelby GT is a 67 and
the new one as well yeah Camaros
Lamborghinis two Lamborghinis Fast Cuts
too fast this is too fast too far it's
all over the place I am now all right oh
it's drove through that dude they don't
even make you go off the line
there's a Skyline right there
am I racing other dudes oh [__] that was
not the way I was supposed to go
God oh you goddamn kidding this [__]
car
oh
all right this there's no way in this
card game I thought I was turning left
go again
screw you guys
oh great I gotta spin around wonderful
how far ahead of the rest of these jerk
offs
two seconds okay
thank you
rev they're drift button like they're
iron casual there is a knock button
there's a mouse button sure is yeah
there was a very motor stormy like that
there we go we're on my way
loot up
there you go
find the building and deploying us kind
of gave you the worst car
it's all right I mean I'm Pro but it's
gotten awesome yeah
it's got this thing called rubber bands
I think everybody
oh Jesus they're blue Turtle let's hope
not
hopefully it's only one lap is that the
popo oh you finished right there
later
[__] sorry kill the person I think I
just ran over that human
yeah
oh oh what a jerk
that's cool
5-10 oh they're from Oakland
great that's right
I got XP not bucks the money is is bucks
bucks the unit of currency in this video
game is books I'm into that
all right
great
how many Bucks do you have I got some
look at these Graphics I think the Box
exchange
is that my dude one to one holy [__]
it's Joel from The Last of Us
with glasses
I need a ride
I got you
like before the the outbreak
fine
yeah I feel like he's just hooked up
with that dude
I need a ride he's like hey hot stuff
let's go
and have how many Bucks
go to the bridge yeah we're definitely
having sex with this dude
this isn't this conversation Alexis is
texting me right now
I don't know if this is um if this will
be voiced in the final version of nozzle
it's not now
what's Alexa saying he says that him and
Brandon are leaving work going to Dada
oh my God already yeah it's 4 20. what
happened which was really funny they
texted me exactly 420.
I don't know if I didn't I'm gonna try
and RAM into these police cars and see
if I get here oh I'm sorry I should be
looking at questions here
unattended oh [__] I've got woman that
left
Mrs objective have sex with random dudes
what you're trying to do that's why it's
called the crew because eventually you
just end up in a massive game I believe
that was one of their talking points at
E3 this year I gotta say online Club I
am very much into the uh the driving
model yeah I liked it a lot when I was
playing it earlier it's tough but it's
kind of like in that it's responsive
like I feel like it's the car not the
trolls
um this reminds me a bit of like the
whole no man's Sky thing where the
actual gameplay is probably not a
million miles away from what you used to
but just the scale of it is going to
make it really interesting like I like
the idea of just driving across
like right now right would you just
drive home yeah you're just trying to
focus I would try to find my house oh
yeah you go to Salt Lake City yeah 100
in that Ford Raptor too because you
gotta have four wheel drives although
they they screwed us and didn't put
Austin in there instead they put Dallas
they didn't put you know Europe in there
so don't feel too bad yeah
they're so gonna put Europe in as DLC or
something great wow that'd be so much
fun
because they made like a land bridge
from like Alaska into Russia
the bearing straight exactly just jump
over it
yeah look at this guy he looks upset he
does because I wouldn't bum him
look at the hipster glasses he doesn't
need those they don't even look like
they've got glass in them
what's going on the cutscenes are nice
that's what I want out of my car
already nice looking cutscenes
look at that bridge like a Lamborghini
the guy
stay low I do all guys I
think that was key for Sutherland
s is that big boss
he's gonna get shot I've seen this movie
so yeah we did not play the first
mission so perhaps this is actually that
has some context I don't know no I mean
oh he looks hungry you're doing
something with your brother as well
and it's gonna get shot yeah
oh exit wound
yeah
prank for murder
look they only had licenses for Forge
okay
finish them off are they
man this guy got shot twice
oh you see what he just did
mine you want my fingerprints off did he
oh it's all set up
now you gotta drive your way out of jail
spoilers
I hope I have to drive my way out of
jail
I mean I don't yeah oh many years later
wow okay you served your time shaving
beard no more beers
and no more glasses same glasses
yeah
but there's tape on them because in jail
your glasses get those goddamn things
off it's true
as well as you
but I'm still having his hair is gray
they're slightly nicer now I think
actually that's Famke Jensen doing in
here the doc gave him
Zoe these are really high quality Cuts
yeah right for a car game I think
I think
I think you can help me if it means
getting me out of prison yes that was
the cop that framed me a million times I
literally told you what kills your
brother yeah they're framed you for his
murder yeah I know
leader of the 510 motor club amen you've
got eight more years in here we can wipe
that slate clean clear your name I said
I'm in so it's it's the it's that
classic holidays
but it's only because you drive good
ones yeah
it's also clearing his name with
something he would want to do anyway
which is get the people who framed him
and killed his friend or brother or
whoever the hell that was yeah like I'm
sure if she just said you're gonna have
to serve your time anyway would you want
to help you go yeah obviously oh no
holes in their face
no okay not yet he's gonna make that
with the pig we'll make out later this
time probably yeah
because video games
the cutscenes are nice they are right
they're really really nice and they're
kind of not that long as well like it's
not like mgs4 cutscenes like just the
perfect right amount of time should we
skip this now yeah I'm gonna skip this
I'm gonna go drive we don't want to give
away this story yeah because everyone's
just dying for that Dormer drills you
drive a cab now hahaha
nope he's got this Warehouse full of
[__] cars and there you go
yo I'm just out of prison oh I got a
bunch
of Amex from the governments to buy my
own car all right all right okay you're
a car you're a car guy all right hold on
you're a car guy okay let's see what our
options are you're not let drive though
because you've been drinking I will not
drive oh you get a fair lady Z or a
Camaro
oh you buy it there okay
how much money do we have we've got 58
58 000 books bucks books remember these
aren't dollars
so dude we could buy like two cards if
he has the most horsepower out of all of
these if you hit a a what happens a just
goes the shirt this is the show right
here I think that's all you can look oh
ah Bingo okay
you can test drive it
or a demo or demo mode what's demo mode
it's like a Wiki app too right trigger
Wiki app
oh yeah horn hit the horn down I'm
oh
the horn opens the doors this is just as
good as Auto Vista all right hi okay
wait you could do the windows there and
everything that's kind of cool hit the
windows detailed
up on the d-pad I am
or maybe the doors need to be closed oh
they do see it going up and down yeah oh
look at the side that's kind of cool
you can make you can make the windows go
up and down
can I do a strong camera
you can't Pop the Trunk
it's full of dead bodies you know yeah
yeah okay cool all right hold on um how
do we get to the next car what's the
name
what's the name ah Bingo okay so it's a
Nissan 370Z I don't want that or Nissan
I liked it I like the Mustangs are nice
or the Challenger you won't let the chat
decide yeah sure I'll get a chat which
one should we get
let's see what is the horsepower the
Mustang 412 although it's probably more
12. what's your zero to sixty five point
one
uh that is that is not there okay
um 4.7 on this though
what I'm saying if this was me right
playing this card game I want sliders
just give me [__] sliders just tell
me which car is the best I've never I've
never driven the Challenger but I kind
of want the Challenger because look at
that you got a 4.6 0-60 you have a top
speed of one is that say 82 370 is that
the Nissan yeah yeah everyone's saying
this that's a good car or Nissan as you
say here no I'm we're getting American
Muscles screw everybody else
backseat driver
before
270 I mean is
early here we go buddy
okay sorry Chad sorry
I I know I asked you but then I just
vetoed you you're gonna be a great dad
it's gonna be like what do you want for
Christmas wrong you're getting this I
think the car got
what happened I think it disappeared
like yeah [__] oh there it is whoa it's
floating whoa
okay here we go
what
what are you saying I can actually draw
no saying they're locked right each
dealer has you can eventually get there
oh so
are the bees are those
can we drive to New York right now yes
I'm almost positive you can by the way
okay that's right where do I think you
can right now yeah I think those are
little lock signs on Miami yeah they are
okay
oh they're all pissed off we picked the
Challenger
ask me if I care Chad
hey where should we go next should we go
to New York
I'm not going to go to New York or what
it says these are locked yeah okay I
want to see if I can fast travel but we
can drive just drive there do you think
we could just drive there I swear to God
you can do it do you think we could just
I think you can drive to New York okay
we're gonna try to get to San Francisco
all right we're having our challenge
that way with half an hour in our
Challenger let's go you want to try to
do it yeah all right we're gonna go
through the mountains just do it this is
a beta I don't think you all right we'll
stop by we'll go ice skating go to
Cartoon or Street [__] off I'm going to
San Francisco oh you gotta turn around
okay cool yeah oh my God yes is this
like driver right you can't I gave me
the fastest car okay okay how good is
this car gonna uh handle yeah probably
not well considering we're going through
mostly mountainous terrain take the
freeway system it's great hopefully the
plows will be through okay this is great
I when I first moved over here I wanted
to do like Route 66 I need that nonsense
oh yeah so this is like I'm doing it but
for free at work you know hey look at
your friends Hey look it's Timothy he
got Z
what about train and everything
I'm kind of into this I don't know I'm
kind of I want you to get to SF really
bad I really like Burnout Paradise and
I'm kind of into this idea of yo it's
like Burnout Paradise except now it's
like humongous and there's no DJ atomica
yeah trailer parts and everything looks
like a great neighborhood this is still
down here this is where everyone in
Detroit lives now
which is ironic because then you can buy
a house through
so they just show the Denny's just show
it when you were like how far you are
for my waypoints at 66 miles copyright
yeah
I guess we'll know in a Mile's time if
it goes down to 65. [__]
thank you well there you go it's a bay
bridge already Timothy's coming with us
so it actually just does the drag race
but we do drag race already oh that's
rad
[__]
I win
hey you know you shut up back there Mr Z
one
what's up Lauren get out of my [__]
way they might tune the car oh Lord's
dead
look at this distance marker without
murdering someone it's pretty good
[__] oh oh I totally just take that guy
out yes Timothy yeah how about that Z
now huh oh
I think everyone in this game had the
same idea
everyone in the beta is trying to get to
the Bay
all right
if we could actually go there in the
beta I'll be super impressed I think you
can I swear it's gonna stop you
invisible walls oh it does no no you'll
make it okay whoa you [__] it's
totally put me into that
what was that
dinner oh it's back here because
skill ghosts oh cool so I guess there's
ghosts on all these little mini missions
too
look at all those guys okay there's
probably loads of your it just spawned
in front of me did you see that nowhere
officer you came out of nowhere
temptress any yeah you have to be a
better driver you have to see those
things before they happen
okay
you're right that's the top side driving
work
all right let's uh we're like truckers
boys on the roads what do you want to do
on the road what's gonna do on our road
trip guys
um
okay uh
Ty you go first okay it can't be I hope
it doesn't begin with C easy let's see
here
um you're driving really fast though
right now I mean 130 miles an hour it's
just kind of hard I spy with my eye
something green oh you do it that way
it's a road sign yes you got it there
you go oh we do it differently what do
you do it why would my little eye
something beginning with
yeah I can't think about it uh you're
still in Midwest right yes something
beginning with
Michigan
with
those are optionally look at these yeah
but they're just there so I might as
well do it that's kind of a clever way
doing it also it's impossible to turn in
this card I gave a really squirrely card
oh my God sometimes it's like I see this
when I'm driving I could do it you've
been in the car sometimes you can start
swerving it yeah and everyone's like
what are you doing well I'm just kidding
them
this is kind of cool all right my
computer's dead so we can't look at chat
he's got it I like I actually kind of
like how they're throwing these just
into the middle oh [__] ambulance get it
away oh you drop a Dodge in that one
that is cool
are you good you guys should follow that
ambulance to see where it leads us
because then we can see it crashes
so from what I was reading these little
like missions and challenges happen
while you're driving yeah yeah it's kind
of cool yeah would you say they're
organic oh get out of my car
okay how far do you think we've gone I
don't know can you get a map
sure can
apparently you've gone four miles of the
in the game well that's uh
let's see how far we are the miles are
like bucks though they're just
all right yeah we gotta wait oh my God
I'm gonna take this is gonna take a
while I thought it was a lot faster than
that no this game is pretty big let's
even get to Vegas
let's go to dykesville dyches Bill yeah
that was on the side free beautiful men
like us we will do so well
um
is that the rocketry statement over here
dykesville yeah no not the town just the
first time the first part yeah I don't
think we can discuss it okay
okay yeah
so to speak yeah
here we go run away it's a thingy so
apparently right I interviewed the dude
one of the creators on this uh at E3 oh
[__] this thing is so hard to control on
its feet and then I stop streaming and
he told me that uh you know that at
trainer they put together where it was
just like the rip bed up yeah yeah so
they thought about that like
the story was they thought about that
like a week before or like a couple of
days before coming to E3 so they
basically
uh recorded that he did he gave two of
his or four of his buddies uh in work a
couple of hours to do it and he said it
took something like two and a half hours
for them to drive from Florida to San
Francisco or to L.A Via San Francisco
okay that's a long time
yeah traffic jam
those are players right yeah yeah that
guy's going to dykesville as well yeah
that's where that's where the thing pops
off at dykesville man
all the traffic disappears once you hit
thugsville oh it's so difficult oh God
sorry man
he or she is dead
on a bridge those guys have countries um
yeah it's Japanese dude does that mean
he's in Japan or yeah is that his flag
it's India in front of us yeah
is that oh
I was trying to yeah he broke like a
boss where are we now what city is this
Chicago Chicago this is the windy city
it came up the windy city the windy
Apple Chicago Old Town chai Town where's
Kanye where's clipping where's Patrick
we're in Chiraq baby we're in
Chiraq oh [__] oh oh
Freight lifter Logistics that's a great
generic title for the driving was more
like this from Watchers probably would
have played it more
oh yeah this is Watch Dogs where's Aiden
Pierce yeah same company though what if
they're probably even an Easter egg or
something oh it probably is
let's see where
let's see if we can we met over can you
like crash into his car and kill his
niece here and
in this video game you are you're the
guy you're the guy who does it
how amazing Easter egg that would be
it's like kill Aiden Pierce's niece
definitely something they put in a car
game yeah
look at this person it's her oh
yeah you definitely can't knock people
down this
I mean they have a teen rating maybe so
yeah
just [__] rampaging Across America
and murdering people State the stage
no kid would do that Danny I know what
you're talking about the area
don't they call the Midwest
or one part of it
everyone's like go to the Sears Tower go
to the Sears Tower no we're going to San
Francisco yeah we might be here so the
problem with traveling across country is
that you could stop and look everywhere
but you have to be oh [__] yeah
exciting what's the liberty down what's
up are you gonna go Liberty okay you
know what let's pull over for a second
guys I want to see if that's the car
behind you
okay you should we should have something
on the way we can't just go straight to
San Francisco we need to Salt Lake City
for Salt Lake City there yeah oh yeah
Yellowstone the ski resorts whoa
Yellowstone is definitely north of Salt
Lake City okay we're going we're gonna
go to Yellowstone first
and then we're gonna head get our way
trucker
and then we're gonna go to Salt Lake
City's at the temple what's the temp
that'd be amazing
good morning Temple oh do you think they
will
if you're making a video game that went
to Salt Lake City it's called The Last
of Us hello really yeah you go there oh
yeah and it starts in Austin by the way
really Last of Us which is even better
they must have done that I've heard like
gunned all these cool cities can I view
pretty well apart from the nuclear plant
in the background yeah
oh wait that was Austin to Salt Lake
City that Journey was Pittsburgh first I
think wow that's so far and then they go
They Don't Really specifically say
awesome but they they have you on Route
71 by Lockhart Texas which is just
outside oh really yeah okay
that's cool and then it goes to like
Jackson Hole
we've been driving for almost a day look
at this Sunset oh we haven't even done
it at night yet that's pretty
interesting
I'm so glad we decided to not have a
look at any of the actual
initial Parts okay people this is what
people want to do yeah I mean come on
I'm gonna play the crew
it's like I'm going to buy this game and
immediately drive home that guy's pissed
off I just cut him off
this is kind of funny because a lot of
if you are actually like driving
cross-country like this is kind of a
commute
so you can just kind of piss people off
by being a dick on the road and then
look how Wiggly that thing is are we
supposed to be giving away stuff yeah so
we've got a beta keys for this am I
looking at codes right now or what uh
for a document here no if anyone wants
to give them if anyone wants one
basically on the games box player so if
you go to gamestop.com and you're
watching this on the player so sorry
twitch people you need to go to the page
to do this uh you need to leave a
comments
and on there just saying something
back how much you love a beta code but
can you just stop in the little Thriller
um yeah North American Keys only
um I believe so make sure you're from
North America good Chinese fire drill
fire drill where you stop at a red light
and then everybody gets out around yeah
that's a Chinese fire drill sorry if
that's crazy that's just what we called
it what was this you stop at a red light
and run out of the car sorry
okay are you mad explain how this works
you had a red light stop everybody gets
out you have to hit the horn though too
you have to hit the horns
does the driver get in yeah
who keeps the horn huh I don't know
about the honking horn oh okay that's
how we did it that's that's where I'm
from Texas bearing we're in Yellowstone
look at that big freaking Rock on the
left
how big was this to download
Dan
I think there's anybody there
how big was it whoa I got shunted there
how big is this freeway look at that
that's awesome
uh uh that was Aidan Pierce's and it was
nice
look at this guy in a truck he's like
oh it's legal here oh it is yeah I mean
how do you get high right now but only
here I'm on probation so when are you
guys gonna have to buy yeah
look how pretty this is It's kind of all
right that's right [__] I don't know
which side
man I don't think they're that bad
they're good they're definitely like not
that bad timing okay
I like the graphics I'm not blown away
but I'm not thinking this is looking
like crap either like it's perfectly
serviceable
where are we now we're on the way to uh
Salt Lake yeah you're in uh it looks
like Colorado yeah it does looks like
I-70 in Colorado
have you been on this road I mean this
is I-70 it looks the person
but it isn't real
I like that the blue line is above you
and not Bryce I'm really into it yeah I
like that a lot it makes it we know when
I was going up the I was going up onto
the freeway there oh
shitly Princess Diana this bad boy
[__]
um I'll be your dirty Alpha yeah oh [__]
oh
the paparazzi yes man we need to break
that one out because I love what he just
said I'll be your Dodie alphaya
so dark
right okay yeah because okay see even
here see they are like driving uphill
yeah if you couldn't see the road you
wouldn't know which way you were turning
like when I was going up that hill I
could see where I was turning afterwards
because it was floating in the air it
was kind of cool yeah yeah there's like
a psychological thing I think that
happens maybe they figure this out with
the line with racing lines and it's more
track based games where in Forza if I
have a whole racing line on yeah for the
whole track and I tend to want to follow
it and that's kind of not what you want
to do all the time depending on the
Dynamics of the race and I actually do a
whole hell a lot better when I turn the
race line off for overtaking and stuff
yeah for just yeah just everything so I
think this kind of solves that problem
where you can still have guidance but
doesn't like it
I kind of don't want you to do this
because I think it might make your car
go out of control blizzard is there like
NOS right now
no no okay only when you're like doing
the racing maybe I have to upgrade it or
something I didn't just buy this car so
yeah oh what's this about in Austin
I don't have enough Escape scale to do
that one
I don't care I'm gonna go see my Mormon
Brethren yeah there you go you think
there's a geyser you think there's Old
Faithful I don't know is that a thing
yeah is that a thing
this is like nothing
in Yellowstone a geezer a geezer
look at this I love how everyone we meet
on is just parked in the middle of the
road because they're all checking their
Maps
because I just realized that's what I
was doing
pretty cool
accurate go back accurate is it gonna
get in the roll over the road reverse
I'm sorry everyone else using this road
but I gotta see this [__]
there they are
look at this it's a Ford bison I knew I
have to wait for No Man's sky this is
Buffalo look at this video game
have you guys ever had buffalo meat yeah
it's so good yeah we should shoot this
guy that's bringing bad news we can only
carry a little bit though it's like
no if you're knocking Trail right oh no
if you knock it down the next person
gets to do it right yeah so could one of
you guys like Drive behind me look at
Kylie here hey Kyle could you drive
behind me
you can't hear it country is Carl from
this is so ominous Kyle knows
something's up hey what's up Kyle
irreversible today Jason's coming at you
if he has any weed Kyle yo Kyle you know
where I can buy some weed
okay let's see how far he goes skylines
how do you get that I think he's bugged
at or something
he's really taking the heart the snowy
cake
run him off the road Danny he's
role-playing he's like I don't have
Chains man
I want his car I want a role play his
wheels aren't even turning that good
he's got his hazards on him
wait is that that effect that happens
when you're driving really fast or yeah
he's picking up speeds oh now he's going
he's freaking out I think this is fake
oh oh he just hit the wall
I don't like you anyway call
isn't that kind of cool seeing all the
airplanes and stuff as well this is kind
of crazy
all Laredo
so I'm definitely gonna buy Forza
Horizon too
see I I like I like arcade erasers
yeah I mean do you guys big burnout guys
yeah I I'd buy that oh [__] I missed
that boat because I was not that into
console games okay yeah I was I put a
lot of hours in they used to be
something called a game Squad I think it
was called Sunday drivers or drive club
or something yeah for a bunch of gay
spiders used to play and then some of us
in the community used to join in on that
as well and that was great every Sunday
we used to do it
[__] and I think like this thing cannot
stop squiggling it's squirrely dude
I got this car this car because I
figured if we're on a straight line it's
gonna be it'll be the best car to have
yes
but I forgot about the tournament
um
you know Ivory Tower is interesting
story because I think they made that
studio just for the skin I think like
they were put together with all these
guys from like Need for Speed and test
drive oh yeah yeah
like doing that game on the PlayStation
of the rally yes yeah they got some of
that team tvu was is a great game
there's not a lot of not enough people
played yeah like test driven limited was
doing some stuff when it comes to like
uh
like open worlds racing games there's
like nobody did even years after like
like before burning I know brother
Paradise gets credit for a lot of stuff
like
that and that was based on a real place
as well that was white right
yeah oh [__] man oh [__] you can look
how well you controlled that it's
amazing dude I was a passenger just like
you guys
I didn't do the physics back here when
you were doing that sorry look at this
thing freaking out in front of me
[__] changing lanes indicate use your
blinkers you're in Salt Lake Resorts now
closer to Andy's townhouse
that's there are tons
man we might I hope we make it to San
Francisco
uh the boys next door don't want to shut
the stream off we might just make it
there
this is my parents house
sorry I don't want you guys
destroy me off just drop me off you just
jump off the freeway there
I don't think there's a freeway that's
this high up
it was in Colorado though yeah
I like what you did there talking about
weed culture
[__] these cars this is like genuinely
difficult like or challenging I should
say because you're in a [__] we're on
the snowy ass Road in a Dodge Challenger
oh I just decided here I blacked out
and you're out too many G's yeah I had
40 G's and it's like that Louie's gonna
crash into the back of that car we know
there's a helicopter I feel my ski City
oh this is kind of cool
this is a good place to be stuck in my
time what hotel is that down there
phones are nearly big enough
I'm gonna get to the ski resort bruh
Salt Lake City baby look at it
really right
it's all good
okay I want you to give an honest
description of how much this I want you
I know what I want you to do is because
that's too easy yeah to describe because
I'm not saying it's
Gonna Be Active I want you to pick out
stuff that is accurate through Salt Lake
City because there has to be one or two
like if you were to make a game about
Salt Lake City it isn't the last of us
and you don't have giraffes yeah what
would be the two or three things that
you would definitely okay Temple Temple
and you need the Salt Lake next to it so
what they need like would they need the
licensing of the Mormon church to get
that Temple oh that's a good point good
question probably
at least you're honest
by the way Book of Mormon fantastic play
honestly maybe because if they can do
that as a like a parent that's priority
they don't it is I don't know about this
all right here we go here we go you got
some people from the stream that live in
Salt Lake City oh really nice
where are they are they over there does
this look like houses in Salt Lake City
no it's pretty good what's Park City in
Salt Lake City I'll go down to oh is
that that looks like City Hall it's
pretty good yeah yeah that's a pretty
good uh approximation approximation I'm
gonna do this red line sorry all right
hey do you want to go where was the
Mormon Temple bee it would be kind of in
the downtown area okay okay
what the Walker Center they got that
right there is a building called The
Walker Center really a different way if
it's gonna snow it like turns red really
yeah it's like they're financially
depending on the weather if I die so
buildings are a little bit
a little bit of downtown please
okay
this is kind of cool this is pretty cool
Temple where would the temple be there's
the capital that's the capital so let's
go go up there so this is State Street
okay it looks right up to the Capitol
the capital's a little bit more on a
hill in real life
going straight you'll probably want to
turn left
I like that the fact that you're even
sickle is amazing so turn left here this
is probably South Temple
it said downtown down here yeah that's
there it is
pretty cool that's awesome oh there's a
tabernacle that's that's really [__]
good
representation of it sorry I just
murdered somebody there so the tap there
it is the temple it actually looks
really good let me let me get some
distance on it
that's where I used to play paintball
the Army Navy circus
you're joking right wow no
Isaac get out of my way we're being
nostalgic for a place
is there a guy called Isaac who drives
around being a real piece of [__] in
Salt Lake City
it's like yeah it's my best friend from
high school like that
I had a friend in school called Isaac
who I used to
call him as a nickname my sack as in my
ball sack I would say call him my sack
and then one day he punched me in the
face and I never called him out again
I didn't realize he was taking it to
heart and that punched me in the face
never ever it's like that right now is
the last time I mentioned that
first
really
that's really cool that they have the uh
Vegas is next I'm more Blown Away by The
Walker Center
they actually had that and
they must have been they must be skiers
who made this and like have visited
all right so what'd you say vacancy
exactly Vegas I'm gonna check the map
while we're driving and see what happens
again
all right what's next Vegas yep
really I think this is so much further
south yeah and then
Central Valley Wine Country Bay Area
we can go through we're gonna go to
Yosemite here there's some wine tasting
how much longer we've left on the stream
so I don't know we have five minutes oh
[__] well no that's until the top of the
hour but of course
you should keep going what time is in
there
it's almost five o'clock oh [__] five
pounds
pick this up tomorrow
okay we can make it to Vegas at least
the question is I'm gonna sleep there
we'll get some blow
and then do some more of this month
they got that song that I used in
gamespot's review of driver San
Francisco the first video I ever did for
this side
they have Olympic Garden
that were all the prostitutes are
something like that
gold medal with a Crazy Horse Too whoa
look at this whoa
whoa where'd that like I would love to
see how they recreate the city I wonder
if that's where my hometown we hit
Andy's Hometown in my hometown is it
through Crazy Horse in San Francisco's
one no no
I thought it was I thought they were
both the biggest I've only been to two
I want to say it's down it's like
downtown stuff
we're in backcountry
don't stop here then
[__] this oh yeah yeah
they said you could do this GPS says
that way Vegas is this one
oh
oh who cares go for it go just go
now there are six specs for your car
apparently and you can actually tune it
for this kind of stuff oh really yeah
even even your car right now you can do
you can do it or like off-road yeah you
get like bigger tires and operates with
suspension do you have like performance
dirt like streets race
Etc that's cool
is there is there a special one for
varying prostitutes yes because I feel
like this is the best place for it the
only thing you can't do in this one is
when you pick them up you can't you
can't let them go and shoot them
so this is this game is kind of I'm
really into it actually this is kind of
great
so I see that I see the Mandalay Bay
right there yeah
but once you do the tour and they have
you know they have the stratosphere like
it'll run out the charm runs out once
you've toured the country yeah then you
drive around in the cities not anybody
left okay better be tight and there
better be good
oh my God we're gonna go wipe down the
strip like there's the Mandalay Bay
behind it should be the Luxor and then
MGM on the right
I love how they've just they're
basically because Vegas is like like one
tenth of Vegas is the actual Vegas
it's such a big city but they've just
said [__] all that stuff we're just
gonna this is the strip and that's it
I cannot believe this beta let you come
here
look at all those people hanging out in
Vegas oh
that's a strip right there right to the
left
atmosphere down there
that's the win that's the wind hotel it
is the new one right it's not new
one for their sister hotels
yeah
downtown man that's old Vegas
Irish we have uh oh that must be
Steven's Irish well Stephen how you
doing buddy oh
is that the one street with the video
wall that goes over the street oh yeah
Fremont
have a look
I got two bucks or something Golden
Nugget yeah oh wow look at that they
actually can't drive that's awesome
there's a great bar in Vegas called
insert coin and arcade bar it's
fantastic when you order like any
console you want when you sit down at
the table oh really yeah
it's fantastic
hey what's going on that guy's Brazilian
sorry your team sucks at soccer
female race I wish you had a German car
right now look at Jake up here look at
Jacob here I don't know why you're not
putting me into the wall mate because
that's all I'm gonna do to you
what's up yeah I'm a dick
that was Vegas that was Vegas all right
I'm not hearing shed so are we can we
I'm happy to keep going
all the way we've come this far we're
making it to San Francisco that's cool
right
all right cool yes yes the road trip
continues I'm definitely going back oh
coyote
I gotta pee
this is so cool I am totally into this I
don't know why this made I don't know
this could end up being like the one
best like really fun time you do in this
game but I will play this game a lot but
I don't know I'm into this [__]
school bus going into the desert night
time what's going on
[__] even bringing those kids who are
you bringing those
all right so we're going through uh
some Nevada this is like the canyon in
Vegas
I've never driven to Vegas I've done
I've gone over to
Yosemite which I guess we're probably
gonna go through maybe I think so are
they big redwoods or whatever this is
awesome man oh it's constellations oh
look at the sky
let's get some Sky pouring going on yeah
Milky Way
oh that's cool Hello I didn't know if
there was in car
this thing car kind of looks all right
who's out behind us yeah
I believe they call this cop
oh [__] oh good that was my sweet drift
look at this guy
putting you on the wall
is that Jacob
I don't know why they give them like
just one-off names here it's not like
because I'm sure that guy's gamer tag or
whatever isn't like Jacob it's probably
like XX Naruto comes out November
November 11th yeah
[__]
sure is Andy
Jacob left
Jacob realized that I want to be his
friend
look how pretty this the night sky is
no more you don't have that ambient
light that light pollution like that
glow yeah
whoa look at that thing's whipping
around the corners
I like the graphics man I think they're
fine yeah they're good
look you guys it's beta content it does
not represent the file quality yeah
they're gonna up the textures yeah
well look at this guy Christopher you
[__] madman I mean we only have
version build three seven six Keys who
knows what three seven three looks like
it's such a deaf thing to do too because
he's on there the left-hand side yeah
look at it I love that look at that it's
like oh it's so sensual
yeah I'm away
I would say down on the Oh okay that's a
nice touch dominant horn yeah but it
also kind of [__] the electricity a bit
see my lights oh that's awesome
oh someone's dead oh I can bring up my
GPS there hello oh you're gonna go with
like a really windy road am I yeah
should I just
forget about the road we don't know we
don't need roads where we're going
all right we don't need roads going over
the mountains Oh I thought you could go
denied
I love that the game still wants me to
go back to the Detroit oh you got mod on
the camera when it did I filled out you
couldn't see it very well because of the
dark
that's your volley next
foreign
yes there's that really funny scene
where they're like the lead character
and that girl he's interested in having
like that really sincere moment like
doing these windy turns and she's like
drifting the whole time but they're
having like this inside conversation
she's like my family just hit me up here
used to drift when I was a kid and
they're both like just swinging back and
forth like this having this really
intense conversation hit me well she's
just drifting all through the road it's
amazing
yeah
it's like really yeah my dad taught me
how to drive it's great where are you
from
this this game wasn't even trying to die
it just goes nah they shot your brother
oh when you're in prison I mean it's a
simple plot device okay who's this jacob
again it is I'm Christopher all the guys
out they're hanging with you this is
like all my they are gonna hang them
with me this is like Journey
this is like I'm going through the game
on the way to the Bay
you do your little like jump up
I can't even go
yeah perfect
I wonder if this is
PS4 yeah I don't know it's just a PC oh
this guy's totally eating the forest I'm
sorry
oh look at the red ones
we are in
Yosemite yo hi Sierra
oh look at that don't get good at this
King Canyon west coast this really looks
actually this really looks like the road
okay Tahoe uh
right Andy it looks like yeah it looks
also like the rode into Yosemite yeah
yeah with the little about foot and a
half height stone wall
is there a uh e-brake
you tapping you break to do those turns
no it has to be right yeah there is
excellent I should have been using that
maybe I shouldn't have it it's pretty
it's holy [__]
what did you learn skip movie
Fresno
nope
[__] San Francisco man we're getting
close we got these mountains
oh this is straight up a bridge
oh let's listen to this we mean like a
real Electric bridge yeah
I'm just remarking on how much of a
bridge that bridge that bridge crosses
the water it's got an entrance and an
exit
s oh Christopher Christopher
hot water
isn't going to run him off the road
there's nothing quite like enjoying the
Majesty of the Redwoods while listening
to [__] trip there how did you get on
the other side of the wall I don't know
but now I think I'm [__] like that guy
at the start of our stream
this is payback here we go bro good yes
whatever dude yep I'm about my own room
yes are you on a train now figure that
one out GPS
I wasn't red is it because I'm off-road
or something you've gone a different way
oh [__] what's up Christopher I mean
yeah you weren't expecting that
yeah
now you're back on the road again okay I
think Christopher was trying to find me
and I'm just pieced out on him everyone
in this game wants to be my friend it's
like the Enthusiast of every other
multiplayer game I've ever played
they're like come on bro stop knocking
me off the road
whoa Jacob Jacob's dead
let him go down
I hope there's not a really fast turn at
the end of this because I'm [__] if
there is
oh
[__] fat I'm sorry I'm so excited
that you can drive anywhere in the beta
that's awesome yeah that's really good
someone said that online I was like no
way they're like he's a badass I love it
yeah when you said it I was like they're
gonna we're gonna hit an invisible wall
no somewhere outside of Detroit but no
it's a dense cannot have said it but I
wasn't I didn't follow sleeping cars a
lot oh God no yeah we're driving all the
time
I have to leave Ireland and London
he wants it for murder oh so many bodies
I've been knocked down twice
there are times a charm maybe that's why
I look left and right when I cross the
road now you know you were true San
Francisco when you get hit by your first
car oh like as a possess yeah as a
pedestrian oh I'm not gonna have like
that yeah really
but I live in Oakland since we have a
difference
yeah don't leave the house you just get
shot Yeah by car yeah all right where
the [__] are we I'm checking my map
below we're going full speed I don't
give a [__] uh all right we're almost
there look at look at how much land
we've covered this is impressive we
started in Detroit right yeah we're
really close okay perfect Central
Valley's next so it's going to be real
boring until we hit
you're coming from the south really oh
you want to do like a well the problem
is you
want to see wine do a scenic route I
know we should just go in the main one
whatever
it's got a sunset yeah we're going to
Benito's house perfect
oh it just stops you all right
space open for crew number three okay go
to Detroit [__] oh I think they want
to be part of our crew can we add them
does it says there's space open Trip
look I know the game's called The Crew
but what I want to do is you're a white
crew we have our crew we're all here
flip the table
sorry I like how the chat rooms now just
talking about no man's Sky we've lost it
oh really great yeah that's awesome
they're enjoying because that's what
happens when you're on a road trip like
this yeah whatever
game yeah do you think I'll ever try to
find true love
uh no you have to work at it no you
don't if you work that's when it's it's
when you least expect it is when it
comes around yeah I feel like most women
run away from you screaming I mean sure
it might be the chloroform I have in my
back pocket but I mean I just
just want to find the one
Andy what's the secret of true love Indy
you know I'm divorced
yeah at least you've got that far
[__]
see this is why we don't talk on our
road trip tear us up okay have you been
divorced or jilted I've never been
divorced
I've had my heart torn out though okay
100 literally yeah like if I can Scorpio
yeah it was very simple to Doom it was
crazy about the new fatalities
David's not gonna know what the [__]
going on watch him look he's like
driving along thinking okay I'm gonna
chips into the corners ass what's this
it's like Ice Cube collaborating with
corn for crappy songs bam Danny is the
Zach Galifianakis of the group
oh God what does that make I don't know
like what that makes me Randy the funny
one we're just oh because if it's like
um I'm the guy who's the jerk
yes that's exactly what we're all
thinking where are we now this is I'm
the guy that got sunburned my country
I mean one that's I don't think this is
not fun
are we talking Last Vegas or [__]
oh the last Hangouts I never saw the
second one what if we were talking Las
Vegas oh [__] I took a wrong turn I
think Danny is Morgan Freeman wait he
was in the third Hangover movie I'm
talking about Las Vegas what's that the
movie with all the old dudes who go to
Vegas were they all gonna die oh that's
like the bucket list
you're definitely
can I just okay cool by the way I know
any movie you're talking about now yeah
it finally got to me I was like wait
what uh
I love this stream it's just us driving
across
hey we're having a great road trip
that's exactly what I wanted to do today
this is what you're doing road trips you
talk about who you are
all right I'm not Morgan Freeman because
I'm not black or from the south or in
any way interesting like you just
screwed both those guys up here sorry
dudes
okay you're I have a feeling these
people are AI I don't know they seem way
too nice oh look at that little cougar
like 30 year old woman or like an actual
cougar yeah she was like running on all
fours across the road I don't think
cougars are 30. yeah
like there's there's Puma
someone was telling me this when I moved
here it was like Puma was like hub
levels of cats women that like younger
men is there lynx
it's like a lion they're a mountain lion
lion lioness the Met line like a real
hairy one
mountain lion like what about a house
cat
what about a domesticated house
domesticated house cat yeah too many
categories
at this stage you might as well just
start
scribing the person it's just getting so
important it just doesn't matter anymore
oh this is a really wide turn I'm taking
oh I think I see San Francisco
this is it you guys or maybe it's
Oakland we're going to pass it we'll be
on the Bay Bridge by the way the shitty
one we're gonna go on the weird oh there
it is oh yeah you can see the Emeryville
oh you can see the 1980s yeah the Ducks
yeah I like it yeah
yeah this is like Oakland here comes the
bridge it's coming up this is it
a bad Bridge you can see the Golden Gate
on the other side there it's a little
close wait yeah shouldn't this be like a
two this shouldn't have Lanes going
either way right yeah
whatever small sacrifice [__] yeah we're
gonna sell this actually kind of looks
this Transamerica
transmitters right there
all right this is pretty good where's
those new apartments that cost like
three thousand dollars everywhere
they're everywhere
yeah
all right all right we're gonna we're
gonna grab a little walk around here for
a little bit guys can we I want to get a
burrito can we stop by the mission yeah
oh we think we're going right here yeah
this is great
that's it
or we can get some Ramen I heard Ramen
Festival going on this weekend
wait what is that all of Nikki
I don't know what that means
I don't look at that [__] playing
this thing oh you need a square
pretty cool
and that guy was drifting
set market so much
okay okay this this is my market right
because let's find the building the fire
dies down there let's find the office
yeah
they had the good parts of that part of
the Market Apple Store
earn Bakery this is great
specialty there's no homeless people
here but otherwise
okay one the sign actually faces the
other way yeah
it faces the water it's also not yeah
that's pretty cool but it does have we
just want to see okay let's see if
they've got 18t and then
okay
or do you want to see the office
sorry this is literally completely
redundant for anyone watching who isn't
from San Francisco now I wonder if they
do that no it should be there I doubt it
it should have already been I think
we're already in Emeryville rnm in uh
where's Tae from again
right yeah because that just scale that
they were working at
been like right next to me okay so what
we want to see you want to see suture
Tower
we want to see we got Transamerica we
got we got the Fair building
what's the tower in town called again
that's quite time quite yeah so Coit
Tower Embarcadero okay let's drive up
here we should eventually hit the Golden
Gate as well see the Fisherman's Wharf
is like yeah
I wish the embarcader was like this
normally that would be amazing and you
can go outside go like 180 miles an hour
yeah
okay this is where Fisherman's this is
like the marina
it's not as happening as a douchebag to
party every day no this is Fisherman's
Wharf you guys have pop collars on over
here that's where the tourists go
Fishman's War downtown cafeteria all
right all right and where's the internet
oh they got the college of fine arts
Olympic
okay we're running into the Presidio
here ain't no Chrissy field but that's
all right
some drug down here
Four Points this is like Mercy Fields
area like yeah yeah oh is that it kinda
right there oh [__]
actually looks pretty accurate on this
are you in the Presidio that's all it
ends right there at the road
all right let's cross the Bay Bridge
into Sausalito and we're done you mean
Golden Girls Golden Gate
this is kind of fun right let's take a
left it's kind of into this next left
yeah I want to see my house
some stuff in these games
this is you know considering they've
tried they actually have the marina
that's awesome but this is
would not be worth this is like we're in
like Clement now
right no no this is Arena that's like
that's like Lombard Street
oh yeah yeah but that's not where we are
at all where we are we're in a [__]
out of Richmond oh and really yeah yeah
like this is this is the left this is
bridge this is 19th run right now right
going north I don't know
go to 540.
yeah so
where are we now we're here
cool yeah so we're like if if this was
real the 540 would be here and actually
oh it's okay with the old Game Spot
offices be right here
the one on Clement
e you gotta turn around I might live
over there
fun times all right looks nothing like
this
no I'll take a ride all right into the
Presidio up to the bridge here we go
so we should go to a Skywalker Ranch and
tell George Lucas that Hebrew and my
childhood
even like the end like those pillars are
actually pretty accurate as well like
it's pretty good let's see what the view
is
it's pretty close that's all and there's
no Carl
oh
there's no one there's no one biking or
walking oh yeah no jumping off no
suicide telephones either
all right into the Marin Headlands all
right
all right down to Sausalito and then we
take the prey back and sit there you're
right right there yeah can we get down
there here we counted
hey [__] you go yeah yeah
this is perfect oh [__] there's like a
like a wall
is it really you finally hit a wall
oh there's like a it's like a shitty
wall
let me set my car
all right eventually it'll open up
there's no cars that are high enough to
show that wall do you think
maybe collapse oh can I reset the car
finish it here yeah that's fine
there you go there you go
we can see Oakland at all all right
that's good we should just take the very
back guys I don't want to drive yeah
yeah don't worry about it let's thank
you Detroit man I can't believe we only
left Detroit what like
40 hours ago look where we started
that's pretty cool yeah all right let's
go to New York let's go to Miami now
talk to Miami
and L.A that took like an hour and 30
minutes or something to that was yeah it
took a while that's pretty cool and we
kind of screwed around a little bit too
so it wasn't like a direct route I feel
like I've driven across an entire nation
that's uh
thanks thank you very much sure I'm
gonna tie root yeah that's the real here
I am that was fun I kind of job guys
that was great we're gonna do this
tomorrow again in the lobby or do
something to disinfect this is probably
just gonna do this to be honest it's
kind of all right uh yeah uh the crew
it's uh available it's coming out
November 11th my good friends uh you by
esoft and this beta is open at well it's
it's not an open Beta but it is
available at the moment if you want any
of the keys if you're watching the live
stream or perhaps if you're watching
this on demand just go into the comments
on gamestop.com and say I want to bet a
key and uh we'll see if you can win one
of those ones North America only though
sadly
um but if there's any European ones
we'll make sure to try and get in on
that as well uh yeah that's been fun
thanks very much hanging out uh Lobby
tomorrow Tuesday 2 p.m Pacific we're
gonna be playing this Abe's Odyssey and
something else
find out tomorrow a lot with us have a
great evening adios